le prêt de la république en marche pour
ces municipales si vous voulez c'est que
comme ils sont un parti qui est très peu
organisés ils n'ont pas de candidat
ils n'ont pas de candidat donc ils vont
les chercher chez autrui et c'est nous
qui nous retrouvons mis en accusation
pour cette situation au fond qui traduit
précisément à mon sens la fragilité et
la faiblesse de la république en marche
ils n'ont pas de candidat donc ils ont
deux techniques pour ça soit ils font de
l'entrisme ils font de l'entrisme
c'est-à-dire qu'ils essaient de caser
sur les listes des conseillers de futurs
conseillers et de futurs grands
électeurs de la république en marche
soit ils soutiennent en volant au
secours de la victoire des maires qui
sont sûrs d'être élu sans eux est
d'ailleurs auxquels ils risquent de
porter quelques peu préjudice parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire que
le label de la république en marche soit
précisément porter donc il faut pas
inverser la charge de la preuve il me
semble que la difficulté aujourd'hui
elle est du côté des marcheurs qui font
de l'entrisme qui font les coucous parce
que ils n'ont pas cette cette
familiarité cet ancrage local